looks like he grew some contact from
edwards but no foul call there he gave
respect to edward
he figured he would try to attack him
edwards walking right into a threes
look at the young man has a green light
that's what's happened here
back in the starting role his 21st start
of the season tonight averaging about 12
points per game is
edwards right inside of the rim well
that dunk early in the year
uh that kind of scares people
speaking of health reports is he this
little runner nice touch there
here's edwards lost a hand momentarily
nader able to recover
step back three on the way for the
rookie got it
no he checks in and he probably did it
to himself in the preseason when he was
lights out
[Applause]
edwards testing the range
edwards the exclusive ball handler
lookouts there's his nightly
highlight jam about power quickness
and a hunger to score this young man
that was
the seas party
and he went for it
[Music]
[Applause]
reed fires it across edwards sets
knock it down his fourth three-point
shot on six attempts waiting on the next
guy it looks like the gorilla
in the fourth quarter with his group
throwing it off the backboard
with the steal and edwards finally gets
it
and slams it home and here it is look at
this i mean this young man got some
serious hops
edwards looking at an even longer three
towns with the offensive glass
finds edwards right to the rim and
that's what he can do
that's why i worry
here's edwards corrado was like no
clear the lane please crowded season
high six assists for mikhail bridges his
career-high eighth that came
early last season as edwards on the
drive gets the finish
and the foul the guy is a poor field
goal
shooter right now although he's had a
good game going
34 his 101st
30-plus points scoring night dropped 43
on the t
wolves back in late february as edward's
adding to his big night
he's got 33.
edward's able to slip inside get the
finish
and the foul edwards with a career high
paul knocks it down but look
it's how you're not crowded
edwards takes the handoff in traffic
collides with crowder gets it off the
glass
and the foul our ninth tie of the night
16 lead changes in this one most of them
came in that first half
edward's inside cp3 nearly had another
steal
but edward's just too strong